[Music]
few things inspire our collective
imagination more than the fragmentary
artifacts of ancient civilizations ones
that once prospered and are now lost to
time looking at objects like these can
make you wonder what other great
civilizations could have risen and
fallen without a trace long ago
fragments of the past is a fantasy world
that echoes the lost artifacts and
fragmented tales of classical history
it's an imaginary bronze age epic a vast
world inspired by ancient mediterranean
myth in civilizations it's a realm of
sun and sea of gods and heroes of war
and fine art this project is the
creation of talented italian artist and
writer massimiliano hamatinon negro he's
released an art book on the epic setting
that much of this video is based on and
i've included a link to it in the
description alongside other ways you can
follow and support him in his book he
depicts imaginary artifacts from this
world pieces of ancient weapons and
pottery and fragments of poems alongside
fully realized images of what these
civilizations might have looked like at
their height there's a lot to cover but
i'll give you a condensed overview of
what's been revealed so far i've found
that exploring the lore of this world
can be a bit like acting as an
archaeologist or historian just of
cultures which never existed sort of
like speculative archaeology if you will
where one pieces together artifacts and
scattered literature so for this entry
into the archive we'll head out into
this fictional world shifting through
the fragments to see what epic
civilizations might emerge the world of
fragments of the past is set on the
massive continent of ascadoria the
imagined record suggests these kuzai
civilization was one of the most
influential in the region according to
legend the zuzai began as a nomadic
horde that raged in the steps beyond the
mountains but came to settle in
ascadoria and built a great empire it
seems the is koozai were people of
contrasts who were revered as both
fearsome warriors and great lovers of
poetry and music the artist imagines the
escuzai worshiped a mysterious and
mighty cosmic beast called the
double-crested panther depictions of
this deity appear in many's kuzai art
fragments and seem to symbolize a notion
we might call change when these koozai
went to war or when death from sickness
or injury loomed over a loved one they
prayed to the double-crested panther for
protection only in the most desperate
and life-changing occasions would they
ask the help of the panther and they
never did so more than three times a
year believing themselves to be divinely
protected the azkuza seemed at one point
to have conquered much of ascadoria
amassing a naval fleet which gave them
control over most waterways with sleek
eel-like boats these koozai upheld their
expanding empire which was composed of
various great cities in particular
betrice was a powerful city-state during
these days serving as both a wealthy
coastal port and a stronghold of his
kuzai military influence some of these
images reveal the splendor of beatrice
in its prime and the unique
architectural style of these koozai
during the period
reading through other fragments i
learned the second culture that
populated ascadoria were the atoy of the
coast a great civilization in their own
right the atoy were a developed and
architectually distinct group long
before the iscoozai arrived in ascadoria
although the izkuzai took over muchatoy
territory in time these kuzai were
transformed by the very culture they
were at war with though in many ways
invaders these kuzai found themselves
transformed by the civilization of the
atoy and began to adopt their cultural
practices like embalming the bodies of
the dead most significantly some
fictional artifacts suggest that the is
kuzai adopted the atoy pantheon of the
gods praying to them in situations that
didn't require the aid of the cosmic
panther the itoi gods therefore became
the most common on the continent the
author has created art of weathered
statues that depict some of the key
deities like farya the goddess of wild
beasts chirta the goddess of the
underground waters
god of knowledge and irigornio the
headless god of music and violence it's
unclear if any of these gods had any
true power outside of myth fragments of
the past is of course a fantasy story so
perhaps these gods could be real within
the context of the narrative in blurring
the distinction between myths and
history however the author highlights
how much of the past often remains a
mystery there are certainly other things
about this fictional world that imply
the existence of the supernatural
particularly when it comes to a toy
rituals in some passages there are
rumors of certain the toy who have
tapped into an unknown ancestral power
drawing strength from prophetic dreams
these individuals were revered as
oracles and conducted processions in the
honor of a forgotten deity the four-eyed
zagrea the cyclically born the eel
ancestor pretty cool if you ask me
there are legends that all the toy
people came from the sea and were exiled
from the water by zagria for an old
unknown crime it's unclear if there's
any truth to this creation story however
beyond the atoy and the zuzai i found
whispers throughout the text of other
civilizations like the agraran builders
of underground catacombs and the
cochleadoi the worshipers of the stars
but much of the history of ascadoria has
yet to be uncovered so instead the last
finding i'll touch on is this figure
huzachi perhaps a spirit perhaps a beast
or perhaps a little god the writings are
intentionally ambiguous but no matter
what huzachi is definitely very old with
depictions of the creature dating back
to the most ancient civilizations of
ascadoria this trickster is apparently
quite mischievous and ill-behaved and
summoned by saying their name three
times behavior aside i'm definitely a
fan of this strange little figure
there's plenty more to the lore of
fragments of the past and plenty more
the author plans on adding in the future
although i don't think everything will
ever be fully revealed as the imagine
gaps are part of what makes this
fictional history feel believable so if
you found the world of fragments of the
past intriguing you can check out the
links to the creator's art book and
social media below and as always thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this entry
please lend your support and like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
see you in the next video and may the
immortal god shield you from misfortune
you